to screen chunky central this episode is
brought to you by mafia 3 family is who
you die for he's welcome to this very
special show kill again
I'm so amazed that all you guys have
come out this morning it's early but
we're broadcasting live from SJ central
here in san diego during comic-con how's
your comic-con been so far pretty good
pretty good I'm so excited because today
and Saturday we are streaming live we
have some fantastic shows if you would
like to see what we're doing here at SJ
central you can watch it live on youtube
on Facebook and also on sj+
just go to screen junkies comm slash
central for our full schedule but I'm
not alone up here I have a very special
co-host that I would like to introduce
please welcome managing editor at
Nerdist and also co-creator and host of
fangirling Alicia leaks hi dub clown
club how's it going yeah thank you so
much for having me Alicia I'm glad that
instead of cloning you they just brought
another Alicia on board yes kind of
works yeah it works them it's easy to
remember it's a great name and you spell
it right yes yes I'm so glad that you
spell it correctly too because that is
the bane of my existence so we're about
to meet some of the cast of orphan black
but before we do that I just want to
take a moment to thank our Plus members
it's because of them and all you guys
that were able to do this amazing thing
so if you want to join and enjoy nearly
20 original weekly shows and hours of
live content joined right now at screen
Joker's comm slash plus and if you use
the offer code SJ central 16 you'll get
50% off the annual membership which is
huge the best deal we could offer woo
thanks guys now let's get into it from
orphan black I would like to welcome to
the stage Jordan Guevara Christian Brune
Kevin Han child and Catherine Alexander
welcome how are you guys good morning
everybody
hey Christian I told you though lots of
people out here look at all you hey
everyone's taking photos thank you guys
so much for coming down to SJ central
now of course everyone knows that season
5 which is coming up soon is gonna be
the last season don't know who I want to
know when that was announced what was
the fan reaction like a lot of flipped
tables angry on social media death
threat will share yeah people were sad
people were sad but we knew it was
coming
yeah we did we time before the integrity
of the show because the storylines were
gonna get really weird for season 6 it
was gonna be the naked season like
everyone's gonna be fully naked they had
to poke they had to pull the plug on
that yeah well you guys know you guys
know Ali shutdown that she's a huge open
black fan she's been with you guys from
day one I think you as said Alecia when
you first heard that it was something
that I loved about what Graham and John
do is that say they let this story be
what it's gonna be and it's not forcing
anything and it's not pulling anything
out and it really just it's such a good
it's such a good little story and very
fundamental about it because this is one
of the first shows I ever covered from
like start to now end and so it's like
no baby but uh speaking of babies I feel
like I got a I want to talk about
Hellena a little bit because I want to
know what you guys think how good of a
mom Hellena is gonna be mildly
protective I think is the right word
she'll feed them well if she doesn't
need all the food first I think they'll
be able to handle themselves
yeah they'll probably just come out
swinging like mercenaries the tiny
little adorable baby mercenaries she
will give them some good
like training some sort of you know
special ops training I think yeah I feel
like since you guys are often hiding now
currently we're in the woods yeah you
guys are in the woods that could be like
a really fun montage maybe like a little
baby training sequence
I think Donnie could use some training
too I think Donnie needs a lot of
training no I think Helene is gonna be a
great mom though really I mean you think
about everything that she's done and all
the people that she's murdered have been
out of this this this sense of right and
wrong and justice and protection of
other people and things that she loves
and she's you could see the tears in her
eyes and the scenes where she's talking
about her little babies and other
people's little babies and stuff like
that so she's got this crazy maternal
instinct that's just gonna serve her
really well and and yeah those kids will
kick some ass no doubt with the riding
on the show is so great and it's always
surprising what is it like when you get
a new script is it is it a surprise for
you guys about where the storylines are
going like ever they don't they don't
say anything to us so we arrive at the
table read the morning of and generally
speaking like we might have a loose idea
of what's gonna happen in the script but
usually it's changed a hundred million
ways what it is it's a constant battle
though where we're always grabbing
Graham and John and trying to pull
information out of them about scripts
that are two or three down to two or
three episodes down the line so when we
do finally get them we all sort of
devour them and we're so excited about
what's gonna what's gonna happen well we
also look forward to comic-con because
generally speaking they're a little you
know what the parties at night they like
to have a little cocktail yeah a little
bit yeah
so once they're loosened up yeah get
them probably gonna prime it some
information of prime
we help them when they're primed
ladies and gentlemen joy yeah I find
it's either trying to get information
out of them during San Diego comic-con
like the first seeds of ideas or like
try to inception ideas in planning like
Donny Donny Donny should get ripped he
should just get a trainer totally buff
and that one didn't take I tried that
one last year my groundskeeper Willie
huh so Katherine I'm so excited to me
you're one of the few people I haven't
met and you do so much of the work you
know that she's rude whenever right stay
incredible at night I'd love to know
from you like what this has been like
what's it's like being a Comic Con this
year and what's it like sort of bringing
these characters to an end with tatianna
yeah well you guys are our first event
it's so fitting I think for my very
first event to be in front of fans
that's really really great really
special so thanks so much for coming and
these guys while Kevin's a newbie at
comic-con San Diego but that he's an old
pro and I have so much fun on the show
Tatiana is amazing everyone that's
shocking
surprise yeah it's great working with
her I think we can all attest to that
and who doesn't want to play like seven
eight twelve different crazy people who
that are all wonderful
so yeah and you're like the tech expert
too because every year we get asked like
how do they do it how do they put all
these women in these frames just like
that
and every year I come out with the same
convoluted like semi confused answer but
you'd probably have a really great
answer about how it's all done or maybe
not me
this is the technical challenge and we
do really strange things but and we go
over budget we get threats from the
studios I imagine when you first started
working with Tatiana it took a little
while to to get the rhythm with her sync
it up now is it faster when you create a
new character together it is a little
faster we we got a bit of rehearsal time
for season 4 which was amazing which we
never get because we had Batson m'kay
there were two brand new characters a
lot of funds we just kind of got to
create the characters so we definitely
have more of a shorthand now and and we
can kind of anticipate like I know I
won't be able to use this side of my
body so I'm gonna do something funky
here when I need to touch you and it
goes smoother but there's always like
the Rachel Sarah clone fight in episode
10 there's always crazy stuff that we
haven't done before so that's the fun of
the show you never know what's gonna
happen I mean I that fight scene was so
badass by the way but I speaking of MK
and Beth I loved I kind of lost my gourd
a little bit at Graham and John when I
saw them after I saw the first episode
because getting all of that Beth stuff I
feel like it's what we've kind of all
wanted to know and it really connected
everything what was it like for you guys
getting to live in that Beth world I
feel like Kevin you especially really
got to work with Beth a lot this season
yeah for me it was a bit of a dream come
true because I mean that's that's the
genesis of it for me and I mean I see
Genesis of the series but that's sort of
where the heart of my character lives
and it gives sort of context as to why
he does the things he does why he is as
invested as he is so to really get a
chance to get into it and explore it and
mind that stuff into to reveal the fact
that there wasn't only just a
professional relationship and a physical
relationship but an actual love I love
that art had and still has for Beth is
really really important because I think
sometimes you can get lost in the fact
that art is very serious
and it's very sort of by-the-book and
and and and law and order but there's
there's a soul behind it and there's a
depth and a an emotional commitment
that's that makes them really invested
in what what's happening with this
estrous well there's so much more to
come with the show do you talk about
theories amongst yourselves of how this
is gonna end how it's all gonna come to
this conclusion I get very confused when
I start trying to see how we can tie
everything up and I have no idea how
episodes babies right yeah like she's
got to have her babies maybe they're
magic
like I think yeah I feel like Kyra's
there's something magical about Kyra
so these babies we know this will be the
spin off this is the spin off Christian
and Felix Johnny and Felix
it's crazy well Alicia why you ask
another question I'm gonna come down to
you guys since we got so many great fans
here today I thought it'd be fun to ask
you guys if you have any fan questions
so I'm gonna go around there but you
keep talking yeah so the funny king of
fan theories I so I obviously love to
put on my tinfoil hat and play in this
game
um we got delphine back at the end of
this season which was right I know I
know clone Club was pumped for that um I
kind of want to know what you guys think
Delphine was up to you on the as I call
it the Cloney island of dr. Moreau
you know Oh tell us yeah she was working
on the new vs Sassoon hair products
by I would buy the shot bodies her hair
is incredible what about you guys have
any other ones you haven't I have no
theory I have no theory I thought she
was camping and they just randomly were
camping on the same island and it was
like a nice happy surprise like me oh
sorry
I just talked I was just thinking there
was one thing that like I caught which
is when I think it was it was one of the
doctors who or the messenger said you
know you can't stay with her you know
you can't stay with her and I was like
what is what does that mean yeah what
does that mean it's a question for the
ages but then and then of course like
the head of neolution van loans get a
loan for your van van Laer
no not Westmoreland but Van Leer
back in the city he helps dr. Cormier
when Ora Delphine when she got shot yeah
he like pulls up with the van and like
yells at Crystal but like he's helping
her out and yet he also bumped off evey
Chau so it's it's I want to know what's
going on with him and his connection to
the island as well it's probably
Illuminati I feel like it's I think it's
the women are rights itself
I've got some questions down here in the
audience I'm over here huh so first up
is one element howdy
what was your question so I wanted to
ask one of my favorite new clones is
Krystal and how you guys feel about
working with crystal and her increased
role in the series Krystal is frankly
quite boring and when I work with her
it's hard to keep my eyes open
there's just no motivation she gives me
nothing as an actor she's a she's a joy
man like honestly you just sort of you
sit in front of her and just and just
bounced off of or just bounce back the
stuff that she's giving to you she's
she's an absolute treat but I think
she's more of a treat in the in the
makeup and hair trailer to see her sort
of get into it and I think Jordan was
just doing his crystal backstage which
are you putting him on this fire
I think I might have put him on the spot
but will he take the bait is the
question okay so let me just tell you
like what's going on right now if you
just keep your eyes like half closed and
just look like you're half asleep always
no one expects anything from you it's
basically like the perfect cover might
be out of a job
what's your name Christine Christine
what's your question for the cast all
right hey guys my question is for
Catherine you just mentioned that you
improved with Tatiana with MK and Beth
or other clones of season can you go
into detail with us like what seems
specifically you can remember what seems
we kind of rehearse for them came back
there's there's unfortunately not too
much room for improv when we're actually
filming because it's so technical right
sometimes we kind of do like button
lines or are we trying to play as much
as we can but in rehearsal we were
really trying to figure out who MK was
specifically so we took the scene the
scene in the trailer with Beth and MK
from after Beth has shot Maggie Chen and
she comes back in we kind of improved
that scene we improv the scene where
where MK is on the like video and Beth
is like take the damn mask off what are
you doing that scene I almost fell off
the stage and there was one more scene
oh the scene in best apartment where she
has the gunite on MK mm-hmm that so we
kind of it was so much fun we just had
like three four days where we sat in a
room and improved kind of those
situations and tense that's amazing so I
had to up my game huge so it was a great
learning experiences fun but yeah we
improved a bit in the the Hellena sarah
tent scene back in season three to the
first scene the fartsy that was did you
improv the fart and was it you were tab
it was me first okay I was lying a first
that's a hot time we had baked beans
thank you thanks guys
I think we ran out of time to do more
fan questions I'm sorry guys there's so
many people here who want to talk but
unfortunately we have to wrap things up
please think that was so quick I know it
was so quick you guys are busy
guys when you're having fun today stage
a demonstration just stay here all day
no we won't Catherine Alexander with a
Kevin Han Chad Christian Boone Jordan
Cabarrus thank you so much for coming
and I want to give a big shout out to
the wonderful Alesha loop my other
favorite Alisha thank you so much stay
tuned to SJ central because we've got so
much coming up for you I'm Alisha Malone
bye thanks again to mafia 3 for
sponsoring this episode to watch our
previous show click the box to the